voilà pet dont
[Musique]
jeanne
mons grand de voir élu pour rendre
hommage à la chanteuse renée claude
atteintes de la maladie d'alzheimer
cette touchante version de succès tu
trouvera la paix popularisée par renée
claude en 1971 et l'initiative du
producteur nicolas lemieux
l'annoncé récente de sa maladie l'a
bouleversé donc à ravir à la variété en
jambes ce soir lundi le deux semaines
qui j'ai dit que j'allais faire vos
chances quelque chose renée claude a
marqué plus d'une génération avec ses
nombreux succès d'une grande beauté
elle incarne cette femme raffinée et les
bras sous
une interprète magistrat qui fait tous
ses textes ses musiques là les faits si
instantanément on dirait que c'est elle
qui les a composées avec écrit ces
textes-là est incandescente pour rendre
hommage à la chanteuse
on a choisi un coeur des cordes et aux
interprètes vêtue et maquillés de noir
comme la chanteuse au sommet de sa
gloire
ce qui nous tenaient ensemble justement
des chanteuses 7,7 a envie d'être là et
de faire ce pour rené son amoureux des
clans dernières années est profondément
ému par le geste
je pleurais tout le long du clip
naturellement parce que le que rené seul
grand amour
qu'est ce que vous aimez de se vider
houleux mais d'abord il est fait très
sobrement il est fait à l'image de rené
ton coeur
le pas
avant elle écrit par stéphane venne
prennent aujourd'hui un tout autre sens
ce texte le en le chantant en pensant à
elle là où elle est c'est fou le sens
que ça prend c'est sûr qu'elle était à
un niveau avancé le maladie mais elle
est très sereine
je pense que intérieurement ce sens bien
sourit souvent chantonne beaucoup les
profits de la vente de la chanson iront
au fonds de recherche sur la maladie
d'alzheimer ici judith jasmin boudreau
radio canada montréal
[Musique]
commencer